今日はこちらスティッカーポイント申します
んいつものように言葉の勉強について話ししようと思います
日本ではやはり外国語というのはいい子
まあ大部分の人たちが英語を勉強しているわけなんですよ
それでその日本語の日本のその
英語版今日しているそのいうまあいえば業界の中には英会話が非常に
大きいなねー
その役割は立っておられますよ
議会は英会話を google 探しますとザクさん
同じ会話
マンツーマンの言い換えは詠歌が学校
た日生まれでしょ
英会話はね英語を勉強する
ための営業のれブラックするためのその
スダン許可
家庭でいうか
勉強を言う方を辞めたしますか
と聞きますねー
まあ役に立たないことはないけれども非常に
恋ず構え
後列が盛りというのはお金がかかる誰か
あなたと英語で話ししてくれる人を探さないといけない
それが日本人であれば
例えば日本語その日本語英語の
という日本人のアクセントの強い人であれば
あまりいい影響じゃないと思いますあるいは
まあ母国語が英語で会うそうでもですね
それがグループ例えば5人でも10人でも日本人の学生とか生徒たちと同時に
と一緒にね一人睦合の
英語の音話している先生が言っても大した
は影響がないと思います
[音楽]
どの言葉を勉強しても
その話するよりもあるいは
会話することを恐れたり感心しその心配したいですねそういうその充填よりも
やはり理解力
理解力が大事
本当によく割れば理解出来ればその自ずから
その発現量が
出てきますハタチします
あのあ時々行きますあの
私はあるいはしてる人が非常に良く
にあの英語予防分かりますけれども非常にその
神経してなって話しできない
まぁそういう人もいるたブヒれないけれども
私はいろんな外国語を勉強しているわけですよ
一番を添えていることは相手の言うことわからないということは恐ろしい
自分があの思うようにあの
発言できなかったと
してる単語してるのにあの非常の時に使えなかったとか忘れましたとか
それはまあなんとかなるわけですよ
それじゃあ言葉を変えてあるいはジェスチャーで説明することもできます
けれども相手の言うことわからないと同種前でしょ
すいませんもう少しゆっくりあの言ってくださいとかねしかしそれを繰り返して
繰り返しているとあまり良くないんですよ
だ
それで理解力を園生
改善するにはですね先生もいらない
永川なグループもいらない
たくさんきっかりたくさん読んだりですね面白い内容のものを
それ用聞いたり読んだりそれに重点を置けば
おのずから以下ヨガ
あの
よくなるんですよ強引を大きくな
で
今は私自身がねぇ
more が午後おけるしぇご登録後3つの言葉をどうにに勉強しています
まあ
今はこれがあるんで僕の計5分ではこれから9分子さん
その道の言葉を同時で今日するつもりであるわけでしょ
でしかしオンライン寄付だとか大和ですねアラブ語会話とか工程車5回が強い柳津
その1時間のそういう d 一眼があればその俺前の旧たと話しするよりもその1時間
はやはり
さらにその日がよくを
36しない
でへ
もちろんまだカーキのリンクししても使ってますねでちょっとあのー
もあるでしょ a
例のために
日本的に僕のその利益での事情
ちょっとお見せしますまず僕のプロファイルですね
あラボずっと2年間
まあ勉強したりやめたり勉強したりやめたりそういう僕のプロファイルで見れるわけ
ですよね
で穴分後で
してる単語が旧線探訪9500看護
んダウンですよで
出会った単語
しかしまだあの
覚えてない単語が山丸合成があるんですよ
それでお抹茶を受けて4弾いいたり読んだりきれい
聞いたりすることによって
この9000単語が1万看護15000タグになってくるわけですよ
で黒子で1000ページを見るとすでに勉強したねさんの日本
お見せしますけれどもやはり多い誰もがないと
それは全部後ろサティロスしょっちゅう s navy t ても
ブーブーも
here
なくなってるわけですよ出会った単語だけでもまだ多い来ない単語も半分
そして覚えたさん5番分
それがやはり一つ商工なんですよ
まだキャッチ少しずつ少しずつ理解の理解力は上がっているわけですよ
新しいその味ラーというはアラブからねええ
本来の新聞からレスモーリーに導入したときにやはり青い珊瑚枚れたんだよ
8卓取らない単語それにあるわけですけれど白い多分
サーチってるターンそしてキーローターんがぁ
勉強中の単語結構色スってどうなるとやはり
その理解力を上げるにはですねそれがいっぺんにすぐというわけじゃないんですよ
それが続けて続けて意味がちょっと曖昧に覚えたりは術たりした単語た種がの中でです
ね施工費ずつ時ずつ理解力が上がってくるわけですよ
そして良い理解量が
あればあと発言のは自ずから
自ずから開設されるんですよだからその限られたんぐ鯉
限られたい単語そのいい会話で
他の生徒たちとかあるいは場合によっては北5-1と
交えて花日すぐにもですねそれほど自分の守備範囲ですね
その理解力
合意を増やすようなことにはなりません
知ってる限られた単語や理解力の繰り返しですよ
しかしさらに拡大閣内拡大にはつながらないんですよ
だから英会話は
それは行ってもいいし楽しければどうぞ
しかしこれは基本のその英語を改善する
手法じゃないんですよそれよりもやはりいくら
ちょっと意味が
十分わからないにしても続けて読んで聴いて自分でその動力してそういうの方が全然
いいです
6日本に行ったときにその表 by
たくさん者を商売に本人とやってた時にですね
時々日本語で時々 a 分
じゃあ日本人がその英語
私のエールが言ったことはなかったと
それで僕はやはり目にいれば分かるわけですよ
それが一番不安なくなんですよ
その同じ日本人でも
僕はやはりは他の像外国のまあ商売人がいいから早く行っても全部わかったとその命て
みればこの日本人が全部わかりましたと時々その英語で何か説明するときに文法が
間違ってたり言葉のことば遣いがちょっと
と
c 前であったにしてもそれは別に大切じゃないです
まず第一番10,000第一大切なのは理解を
だから
英会話じゃなくて理解力に重点を置いてくださいそれで動くのその日名誉
10%ぐらいになーぐちを頭や体言葉を提供する
あっ塗料 a
もらいたいならばこのリー
者のもう